Das ist wirklich verrückt menschliches leben 24 jahre lang eingefroren und jetzt am leben können also menschen der nächst
eingefroren werden und jahrzehnte ja jahrhunderte später aufwachen wenn zum beispiel ihre unheilbare krankheit geheilt werden kann
Der weltrekord für ein gefrorenes menschliches leben jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Emma brenn gibson ist ein sehr seltsames bbs wurde als embryo eingefroren und zwar vor
24 jahren am 14 oktober
1992 und am 25 november
2017 kam emma auf die welt ihre mutter tina gibson die sie in bunten hat ist heute
26 jahre alter sms embryo eingefroren wurde war sie selbst noch ein, baby
Wie soll das bitte geh jetzt mal langsam und ganz von vorne im us geschichte beginnt also
Im oktober 1992 eine anonyme spenderin erklärt sich bereit ihre bereits befruchteten eizellen zur verfügung zu stellen beispielsweise
passiert das wenn die eigene familienplanung abgeschlossen ist die embryos entstehen bei der sogenannten in vitro fertilisation
Hier werden, im labor eizelle und samenzelle vereinigt der embryo kann dann in die gebärmutter übertragen werden in den usa
Gibt es aber eben auch die option den embryo zunächst einmal einzufrieren das alles läuft dann über bestimmte kliniken wie
beispielsweise dem national education center, im amerikanischen knoxville in tennessee das motto
Adoptiere einen embryo laut website sind dadurch bereits mehr als 680 kinder geboren worden
Es gibt schätzungen nach denen alleine in den usa bis zu einer million embryos eingelagert sind sie werden auch als snow
babys
also
schnee babys
bezeichnet eine chance für menschen wie die
amerikanerin tina gibson und ihren mann benjamin die sich unbedingt kinder wünschen doch er ist an der stoffwechselkrankheit mukoviszidose
Erkannt und das steht ihrem kinderwunsch. Im weg das paten
Im pflegekinder auf und denkt über eine adoption nach doch dann erfahren sie von der möglichkeit
einen embryo zu adoptieren die beiden dachten lange darüber nach doch dann stand ihre n scheidung festina bekam entsprechende
Medikamente und es gab viele gründliche untersuchung
um festzustellen ob solch einen embryo einen transfer tatsächlich klappen könnte zudem
wurde auch die familiäre situation und das zuhause der gibsons sehr genau
Durchleuchtet eben um zu schauen ob ein kind in diesem umfeld vernünftig aufwachsen kann ähnlich wie
bei einer gewöhnlichen
Adoption im märz 2017 war es dann soweit
der embryo wurde in tinas gebärmutter eingesetzt die ärzte erzählen sich die anekdote dass sie damals wohl noch folgendes gesagt hatte
Sie hätte meine beste freundin sein können und tatsächlich das schnee baby war im oktober
1992 gezeugt worden und war somit bereits
24 eineinhalb jahre eingefroren vorher hatte benjamin aber tatsächlich die wahl aus etwa dreihundert profilen
Unterschiedlicher embryonen konnten sie auswählen dazu tina es ist überwältigend es sind so viele wonach
Wählt man aus?
Das paar entschied unter anderem dass es ein kind werden sollte das als erwachsener nicht besonders groß
werden wird denn auch die beiden sind eher klein schließlich
wurde tina dann ein weiblicher embryo eingepflanzt deren profil dem ehepaar gibson
Am besten passte mit der schwangerschaft klappte es dann sofort die neun monate verliefen
relativ
unkompliziert
Weltrekord heißt es jetzt überall doch tatsächlich ist es gar nicht
So einfach möglich die ältesten bekannten embryos zu identifizieren denn die unternehmen in den usa?
Sind lediglich dazu verpflichtet das ergebnis der schwangerschaft nicht aber das alter des embryos
zu melden in einer studie von 2011 jedenfalls wird von einem
20 jahre alten embryo
Berichtet den gibson ist das alles total egal dazu tina ich wollte bloß ein baby haben mir ist es egal ob es ein
Weltrekord ist oder nicht in medienberichten heißt es weiter dass wohl auch
geschwister für immer möglich sein denn in der klinik seien sogar noch weitere embryos mit genau dieser den
Wenn ich exakt aber geschwister
dna
Am start aber ist das ein indiz dafür dass wir in zukunft vielleicht menschen
einfrieren und wiederbeleben können ich werde demnächst auf jeden fall darüber berichten wenn ihr das video nicht verpassen wollen und auch
zu allen anderen themen informiert werden wollt dann drückt mir hier einen abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht denen
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür braucht gegen ewiges leben
möglich ja ansonsten
bis dann